[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat participation en
hausse poussé des partis du
rassemblement national et d'europe
écologie les verts lésions pour les
élections européennes 2019 ont parlé le
26 mai dernier dans les yvelines la
liste est la vraie modem arrive en tête
alors quels enseignements pouvons nous
tirer de ce scrutin notamment dans notre
département
c'est le débat du jour et j'accueille
autour de cette table quatre invités
didier baichère bonsoir vous êtes et
député les rues même pour la première
circonscription des yvelines david
douillet bonsoir ou trois secrétaires
europe ecologie les verts pour l'île de
france
en face de vous si rim note françois
vous échouez en mai rassemblement
national pour mantes la ville s'est
également conseiller régional
d'ile-de-france et puis stéphane mention
soir là vous êtes le professeur de droit
public à lui vécu et à sciences po
saint-germain merci d'être présent ce
soir juste une précision le party les
républicains avaient été conviés pour
cette émission mais a décliné
l'invitation
alors pour commencer tout de suite et
bien je vous propose de regarder ce
micro trottoir
nous avons demandé aux saint quentinois
ce qu'elle pensait du résultat de ces
élections
pas de beaucoup de surprises et
malheureusement
on voit qu'il ya une montée l'extrême
droite donc c'est désolant mais c'est un
peu l'image de la france aujourd'hui les
gens se sont un peu désintéressé c'est
pour ça que il n'y a pas eu autant de
mobilisation par les urnes et de
l'étonnement
mais pour le coup je pense qu'on s'y
prépare et tous
j'éprouve une grande tristesse parce que
les gens ont peur et je crois qu'ils ne
savent pas prendre des vraies solutions
les bonnes solutions et puis bon on est
quand même mal gérer au mieux le dire
maintenant passe carrément à l'opposé à
l'extrême droite du coup je trouve que
c'est un peu abusé après je peux pas
trop m'exprimer parce que moi j'ai pas
j'ai pas voté donc j'ai pas le droit de
me plaindre alors quelques chiffres pour
compléter son micro trottoir dans les
yvelines la liste elle est vraie modem
arrive donc en tête avec 29 points 96 %
des suffrages alors qu'elle n'est que
deuxième en france
toujours dans les yvelines europe
ecologie les verts arrivent à deuxième
alors que cette liste n'est que
troisième en france dans notre
département rassemblement national est
troisième alors que ces partis est en
tête en france on retrouve après dans
notre département les républicains à
place publique et la france 1 sont mises
alors stéphane minson
je me tourne vers vous comment analyser
analyser vos parts dans ses résultats
mais qui fit notamment ces différences
entre balises yvelines et puis les
résultats nationaux
globalement les résultats sont
correspondre à peu de choses près ce
qu'on attendait du moins pour les deux
listes arrivées en tête avec un écart
qui est très faible de 0,9 point avec
néanmoins un effet loupe
c'est vrai que le président la
république c'était très investis à
l'image des autres risquent pas plus
investis que plus ou moins que que ne
l'avait fait hollande ou sarkozy en leur
temps un effet loupe qui évidemment
consacre le rassemblement national en
première position mais avec un écart
relativement faible et puis la surprise
alors qu'équipe de mon point de vue une
demi surprise c'est le sait le bon score
d'europe écologie demi surprise parce
que nous on sait que traditionnellement
les scrutins repères sont plutôt
favorables à europe ecologie c'est un
scrutin de liste à la proportionnelle
intégrale
et puis on sait qu europe ecologie les
verts parmi les hausses un de l'offre
politique nationale est sans doute l'un
des partis qui le plus tôt a compris la
dimension européenne de ce2 ce2 de ces
questions-là questions d'environnement
d'écologie aujourd'hui elles sont de
toute évidence européenne mais eux élevé
l'avez compris peut-être avant les
autres et puis votre enseignement mais
c'est évidemment l'effondrement
catastrophique de des républicains y
compris dans les yvelines pour répondre
à la seconde partie de votre question et
ça c'est plutôt une surprise
il n'y a pas de raison qu'il y avait
aucune raison que les yvelines résistent
à cette vague les fastes pour les
républicains
mais à ce point je crois que ça c'est
une véritable surprise
je vous propose de regarder cette carte
du département avec les listes arrivées
en premier dans plusieurs communes on le
voit située au nord des yvelines et bien
c'est le rassemblement national qui est
arrivé en tête
cyril noter ce que vous vous attendiez à
ce résultat oui est conforme
ces résultats sont conformes à ceux des
élections précédentes le roi
rassemblement national est
traditionnellement fort dans le
nord-ouest discipline il ya également
une pointe au sud
je me permettrai de compléter
l'intervention de monsieur professeur
concernant les résultats au niveau
national j'aimerais préciser que nous
avons obtenu cinq cent mille voix de
plus à ces élections là que par rapport
il ya cinq ans malgré une participation
en hausse
d'habitude nous on nous dit que nous
sommes bénéficiaires de l'abstention là
c'est pas le cas malgré le surcroît de
participation nous avons amélioré notre
score nous avons également améliorer
notre score en pourcentage par rapport à
l'élection présidentielle de 2017 ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la république en
marche et je précise aussi que nous
sommes partis seuls à cette élection
sans alliés ce qui n'est pas le cas de
la république en marche puisque l'état
dit avec le modem agir et les radicaux
de gauche
didier baichère que vous voulez
peut-être ajouter quelque chose par
rapport au processus je pense que ce
résultat est
extrêmement intéressant il ya deux
niveaux le niveau national et au niveau
local on y reviendra sur le niveau
national c'est intéressant de voir
finalement on a si peu d'écart avec le
front national alors que finalement il
ya eu très peu de campagnes sur les
européennes en tant que tel le front
national et la france a soumises ont
appelé à faire un référendum anti macron
moi je dirais compte tenu du contexte
national qu'on a quand même depuis six
mois avec cette tentative de ces mêmes
partis politiques de récupérer les gilet
jaune et cette volonté vraiment
explicite de faire campagne contre
macron au final on termine avec le même
nombre de députés européens la
commission donc sur ses patins après le
break situera 23 les mêmes on aura damon
nombre de sièges chacun donc c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle et on se
maintient on se maintient clairement
est ce qu'on peut parler de victoire de
comment vous analysé ce résultat je
pense qu'elle n'avait pas fait manger on
a eu beaucoup beaucoup de commentaires
sur la défaite des républicains
je crois que ce qui est surtout
intéressant c'est le succès de la
république en marche on est dans un
département qui traditionnellement est
plutôt centre-droit on est aussi dans un
département où il ya une campagne qui a
été fait de manière intensive pour
françois-xavier bel ami avec monsieur
larcher madame pécresse
le maire de versailles qui était présent
à l'ensemble des meetings de
françois-xavier bellamy qui est lui même
élu à versailles depuis 2018 et ces gens
me dire un des échecs qui se poursuivent
il ya eu la défaite aux législatives
pour françois-xavier la wilaya il ya
vraiment un message très fort qui est
envoyé dans les yvelines mais
particulièrement sur la circonscription
de la première circonscription qui est
la même et en particulier à versailles 1
puisque la république en marche est
arrivé en tête à versailles là où
françois xavier
bellamy normalement et est plutôt
instauré c'est un enseignement en fait
deux je pense que la sociologie évolue
énormément les citoyens sont beaucoup
plus près à comprendre que le clivage
gauche droite franchement n'a plus aucun
sens là où les partis politiques
peut-être anciens s'accrochent encore à
ce clivage gauche droite qui honnêtement
n'a plus aucun sens si on va le voir
avec les municipales où il va vraiment
être question de projet de ville et pas
du tout de gauche droite stéphane minson
par l'epita la surprise verte
dire ça comme ça david juste yédiot
également une hausse de la participation
s'attendaient à une participation plus
basse est ce que vous pensez que cette
hausse de la participation à peut-être
été bénéfique pour europe ecologie les
verts
certainement en particulier chez les ch
et des jeunes on a vu que les
générations qui vont arriver qui sont
les plus préoccupés par les politiques
qui vont les concernés directement ont
massivement place et l'écologie
politique en tête de leurs de leurs
bottes à plus de 35% dans la classe
d'âge 18 35 ans donc évidemment la
housse delà de la participation est très
certainement lié à ce vote des jeunes
qui s'est massivement tournés vers vers
l'écologie
et puis elle nous a sans doute profité
également parce que on double notre
score certes par rapport à la dernière
élection de 2014 mais en pourcentage
mais si on regarde en nombre de voix on
est encore au dessus de l'élection
précédente celle de 2009 on avait fait
un score assez historique un petit peu
plus de 16% là avec notre aise et demi
pour cent sur l'ensemble de la france en
nombre de voix on est quand même au
dessus donc évidemment il ya eu alors
une vague verte peut-être que le mot est
un petit peu exagéré parce que ce n'est
pas encore une victoire pour nous
aujourd'hui c'est un très beau succès on
s'en félicite
la vague verte elle arrivera lorsque on
sera premier comprendra le pouvoir et
que nous serons le premier groupe au
parlement européen en tout cas c'est un
très beau succès on va envoyer en tout
70 eurodéputés à l'échelle européenne
pour former un groupe vers autonome
puissant et qui va continuer à apporter
les envie d'écologie des envies de lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique de
transition écologique de solidarité de
justice sociale à l'échelle de l'europe
qu'attendent toutes celles et tous ceux
qui ont voté pour pour nous en france et
dans les yvelines puisque vous le vous
l'avez souligné
nous arrivons en deuxième position dans
les yvelines
à l'échelle du département et dans un
grand nombre de villes très importante
sartrouville par exemple nous sommes
deuxièmes ici à saint quentin en
yvelines on arrive deuxième dans
des douze communes de l'agglomération on
arrive deuxième à rambouillet ou chez
lui j'en suis extrêmement content donc
il ya une vraie envie de transformer
toutes les luttes toutes les marches
pour le pour le climat les buts sur le
sur le terrain en un projet politique et
maintenant c'est à nous d'être à la
hauteur de cette attente de cet enjeu
est de transformer en un projet en une
offre pour les prochaines échéances a
longtemps et la participation qui était
en hausse donc supérieure à 50 % au
niveau national dans les abîmes 53 92 %
est ce qu'on peut parler de sursaut du
sentiment européen avec cette eau de la
participation
tiens une note par exemple je ne sais
pas pour pour prolonger l'intervention
monsieur et le score est effectivement
assez significatif d'europe écologie les
verts il pense représenter un espoir
mais en même temps lorsqu'on lorsqu on
note qu'à l'élection présidentielle qui
a suivi de l'excellent score de 2009
je crois que votre candidate et eva joly
elle a réalisé un score qui est très
faible autour des entre 2 et 3%
en réalité les bon score d'europe
écologie les verts n'ont souvent pas de
suite aux autres sélections nationales
j'aimerais également revenir sur le
score de république en marche qui a qui
a certes et on peut le regretter en tout
cas de mon point de vue a réussi à
limiter la casse et et des dégâts avec
seulement un point d'écart avec le
rassemblement national
mais en réalité c'est parce que emmanuel
macron a été contraint de renoncer une
grande partie de son projet on dit qu'on
va distribuer près de 20 milliards dans
le cadre du mouvement social ddj des
jaunes et ça c'est évidemment
significatif il en train de faire de la
social démocratie à la halle à françois
hollande
et lorsqu'il va reprendre un certain
nombre de réformes très sensible je
pense à l'assurance chômage ou bien
retraite
peut-être que ce mouvement reprendra à
nouveau une certaine vigueur répondre
oui je sais pas ce mouvement reprendra
une vidéo pas ce qu'est ce qui est
important c'est que on a essayé de se
mettre dans une dimension où on écoute
ce qui se passe sur le terrain et
essayer de répondre à un moment donné
à cette difficulté je pense que les 29 %
par exemple d'illinois qui ont touché la
prime d'activité en plus qu'ils ne
touchaient pas la prime d'activité
jusqu'à maintenant je pas sûr qu'ils
aient le même raisonnement que monsieur
il voit qu'à un moment donné il ya un
problème de pouvoir d'achat qu'on a
répondu à ce prime de pouvoir d'achat
et c'est pas 2% ou 3% ses 29% divino à
supplémentaires qui touchent la prime
d'activité s'en allaient dégrader la
situation économique de nos entreprises
ça c'est aussi un point je pense
essentiel qui nous qui nous démarque
avec les républicains se dire que nous
on se bat une forme de libéralisme
économique mais non pas pour les
actionnaires gagnent de l'argent en on
se bat pour que l'emploi se développe
parce que si les entreprises vont bien
il ya de l'emploi et donc il ya du
travail pour tous c'est ça notre
engagement essentiel et c'est aussi ça
qui nous différencie des républicains et
je pense que les françaises et les
français comprennent cette différence
stéphane maintenant je parle là aux la
participation à quoi à quoi est ce dû
finalement est ce que parce que la
campagne a été hâtée bonne est-ce que
l'ailé les français se sentent plus
européen peut-être qu'avant plusieurs
observations la première ses consoeurs
ont s'extasient devant cette porte
devant cette participation est en hausse
c'est vraiment à 50%
ça veut dire qu'un électeur sur deux n'a
pas voté donc ça n'est pas satisfaisant
évidemment et c'est un chiffre qui est
meilleur mais qui reste très bas dans le
contexte de la vie politique française
jusqu'à présent du moins
et puis d'autres observations sur la
cause pourquoi est ce que les gens vont
voter pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
s'abstiennent en général parfois assez
souvent l'abstention c'est une posture
politique qui peut se concevoir qui peut
se comprendre
la participation à ces plus c'est plus
compliqué vous disiez est ce que les
gens se sont emparés des enjeux
européens je sais c'est pas improbable
au regard de la situation assez ça a été
dit pendant la campagne d'ailleurs assez
unique dans laquelle se trouve
aujourd'hui l'union européenne au bout
de quarante ans d'existence fin
d'existence démocratique depuis les
premières élections sont 19
je pense que certaines certains
électeurs se sont dit c'est peut-être le
moment d'aller d'aller aux urnes
je pense qu'il ya eu aussi pour la
france en tout cas et ça je crois que
c'est une excellente chose
le retour à
des listes nationales souvenez qu'aux
précédents scrutins sont des listes par
grandes régions qui finalement j'allais
dire motyka c'est peut-être un peu la
motivation de certains faisaient les
électeurs qui en tout cas la lisibilité
de la campagne et puis je poursuis
délicat de les comparer du fait que
cette modification majeure
et puis il ya il ya peut-être eu le
brésil qui alors suscité quand même pas
mal de débats chez nous et puis
peut-être une certaine crainte alors que
plusieurs partis politiques avaient
modifié leur programme en fonction de
cela notamment mais je pense pour en
avoir parlé avec certains c'est pas la
valeur de sondage mais que ce break site
a peut-être donné confiance à pas mal de
citoyens que l'europe s'était peut-être
pas si pire que ce qu'on voulait bien le
dire mais c'est justement sur leur
excellent je tiens à dire que quand même
que les britanniques ont semble-t-il
confirmer leur vote en votant
massivement pour la liste de nigel
farrage alors justement pour parler du
bric site après le bric site donc à ce
rassemblement national et elle est
vraiment obtiendront tous les deux donc
23 sièges très siège pour europe
écologie et les verts
huit eurodéputés pour les républicains
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
alliance peut-être entre europe ecologie
les verts je ne sais pas qui et puis
aller rue m
est ce que c'est possible
traditionnellement et c'est quelque
chose qui va perdurer
les verts européens ont un parent qui
commet un groupe comme un os
au parlement européen et il est
absolument pas envisageable aujourd'hui
de fusionner on a un espèce de grand
groupe central c'est pas du tout le
l'objectif que nous on s'était fixé
c'est encore moins ce que nous avions
annoncé aux électeurs et aux électrices
pour les pousser à voter à voter pour
nous le fonctionnement du parlement
européen
il est un petit peu particulier par
rapport à ce qu'on connaît ici en france
on a deux blocs très clivant
l'opposition la majorité et quel que
soit le projet qui votait la majorité va
votre pour l'opposition votre contre et
c'est pas du tout comme ça que ça
fonctionne au parlement européen donc
évidemment sur certains sujets il va
falloir aller trouver des coalitions
mais ça va se faire projet par projet et
nous les écologistes nous aurons comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure un groupe
autonome fort de 70 parlementaires au
parlement européen et on portera les
valeurs les idées qui sont les nôtres et
celle qu'on a défendu il faut tordre le
cou à toutes ces rumeurs qui d'ailleurs
viennent pour beaucoup de la république
en marche qui effectivement nous nous
envoie nous envoie des appels à une
improbable alliance avec des libéraux
qui depuis toujours sont sur des lignes
politiques très différentes des nôtres
lorsque nous on dénonce vigoureusement
les accords de libre-échange cette
mondialisation anarchique les libéraux
la défendent bec et ongles lorsque on
dit qu'il faut engager au plus vite la
transition écologique il faut défendre
les territoires que il faut lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique
systématiquement les libéraux au
parlement européen font obstacle à nos
propositions
donc ça va être extrêmement compliqué de
trouver des accords de ce côté-là de
l'échiquier politique
évidemment à l'essai répond didier
baichère déjà c'est une excellente
nouvelle
moi je trouve le résultat des
écologistes parce que ça montre que
c'est un sujet majeur
d'ailleurs enfin je pense qu'on s'y
était pas trompé puisque le deuxième de
liste de la république en marche
effectivement un écologiste et on avait
un autre député européen écologiste
c'est effectivement tant que la même
chose que nicolas hulot allait coloniser
en l'arche bon courage à lui dans mes
sélestat ce que c'est qu'un public
lajoux qui est important c'est que notre
deuxième de liste il était sur des
sujets d'écologie donc c'est bien
quelque chose qui est essentiel pour
nous et je pense que vous l'avez très
bien d'écrivains ou dans le doute sur
ses convictions écologistes
je pense que c'est important au sein de
votre groupe g choix je pense que vous
avez très bien expliqué le
fonctionnement du parlement européen
en tout cas en termes de progrès si je
suis certain que sur certains textes on
se retrouvera et que personne n'imagine
qu'on va fusionner avec les verts ou des
choses comme ça c'est en tout cas il
n'est question posée à terre il va y
avoir des alliances des avions sur des
textes oui forcément parce qu'on
commençait le fonctionnement du
parlement européen et là on est dans
cette situation où de toute façon aucun
des grands leaders historiques n'a la
majorité suffisante pour se débrouiller
en faisant des petits bouts
d'associations y aura forcément seconde
centrale
il va jouer un positionnement important
mais c'est aussi je crois le signe pour
la suite qui est important de dire que
c'est le message qui est envoyé
c'est que l'écologie n'est plus quelque
chose qui est accessoire donc il faudra
dans tous les projets et nous encore une
fois on l'a montré très fortement sur
les élections européennes que c'était un
sujet qui nous importait et dans les
combats qui vont venir sur sur les
municipales par exemple ça sera quelque
chose qui sera tout à fait central note
est ce qu'il va y avoir des alliances
peut-être avec les eurodéputés
rassemblement national avec j'aimerais
d'abord dire un mot sur ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est vrai qu'on a senti
pendant qu pas d'une tentative de
séduction et de drague de la part de la
république en marche auprès de
l'électorat sensible à l'écologie mais à
un moment donné
l'écologie la vraie écologie et l'ultra
billets libéralisme c'est incompatible
donc il va falloir faire des choix
effectivement je veux je pense que les
alliances entre ces deux familles
politiques seront seront impossibles
en ce qui concerne le rassemblement
national des discussions sont en cours
le but c'est bien sûr de fonder le
groupe le plus important possible pour
peser au parlement européen les
observateurs de la vie politique en 2014
avait nous avait promis comme
l'échauffourée a fondé un groupe nous
avons réussi là je crois qu'avec matteo
salvini notamment qui a réussi
brillamment ces élections en italie nous
non moins de difficultés à réussir ce
défi
stéphane montrant ce que la commission
européenne va changer de visage
forcément
ne serait ce que parce que
là haut de la du président de la
commission la commission doit être et
c'est très bien et enfin ça n'a pas
toujours été doit être plus ou moins le
reflet de des couleurs du parlement
européen doit tenir compte
c'est l'expression exacte du vote des
citoyens européens
on arrive bientôt à la fin de l'émission
on encore 5 minutes pour parler
notamment des des élections municipales
forcément puisqu'on est à moins d'un an
des élections municipales
est ce que justement ces élections
européennes on peut dire qu'elles ont
modifié le paysage le paysage politique
yvelinois je prends soin qu'elles l'ont
modifié sa chacun partira comme bhl
estime qu'il doit partir mais c'est
surtout qu'il faut intégrer je pense aux
aux alliances qui peut y avoir un peu
historique dans les yvelines dans nos
différentes villes je pense qu'il faut
comprendre maintenant très vite que les
citoyens n'attendent pas ce clivage
gauche droite qui étaient installés
depuis des années qu'ils attendent des
projets de villes et des projets de
villes ça doit se faire de manière très
très large pour l'intérêt de la ville en
tout cas pour la république en marche et
ce que nous avons cherché sur les villes
essayer de savoir si on a un projet
commun si on se retrouve sur un certain
nombre de valeurs
en essayant de s'écarter le plus
possible de ce clivage gauche droite qui
encore une fois confirmé dans les urnes
ce week-end n'intéresse plus les
français
on a vu que la république en marche
arrivé en tête notamment pour ces
élections dans plusieurs communes est ce
que c'est un signal pour vous un signal
fort pour justement
ce crétin 2020 c'est un signal d'ouvrir
les négociations 20 mois j'attends aussi
que les maires en place concernée ce
sens fin commence à discuter avec nous
des projets et on verra au cas par cas
en fonction de la volonté d'avoir un
vous êtes sur la première
circonscription a versé choisis l'ont
fait rire ça avec monsieur de matière
par exemple oui je pense qu'à verser des
choses qui sont extrêmement intéressante
qui sont en place et tout n'est pas tout
n'est pas à critiquer maintenant bien
évidemment il ya un certain nombre de
sujets sur lequel je pense au
développement économique à la jeunesse
qui n'a aucune place aujourd'hui à
versailles
il ya des fondamentaux sur lequel nous
on va vouloir travailler si des équipes
en place font envie à un moment donné de
raccrocher notre projet est développé
des sujets qui n'ont pas développé
jusqu'à maintenant et qui intéressait
citoyens on pourra s'associer au cas par
cas bien sûr c'est est-ce que selon vous
ces élections ont modifié un petit peu
non je crois que je partage tout à fait
votre point de vue je pense que les
électeurs les administrés lorsqu'ils ont
un bon maire ils veulent le garder et je
préoccupe pas de l'heure de sa
sensibilité politique août sur
l'étiquette
ils peuvent très bien voter à gauche au
niveau national et votez pour un maire
de droite s'il estime qu'il fait bien
son travail
je me permets de parler un petit peu de
membres du cad montre la ville et de
préciser que leur candidat l'année
prochaine sans doute oui je je le dirai
en d'autres temps d'autres via d'autres
moments mais mais effectivement je tiens
à préciser que nous avons obtenu le
score de 26 7% et que l'écart est
beaucoup plus important que la
république en marche qui qui a atteint
les 18 % des communes je crois d'île de
france
en fait c'est la seule en dirigeait donc
par en un rassemblement national il me
semble que c'est qu'on a obtenu un des
meilleurs scores dans les communes de
plus de 20 mille
habitant en tout cas à m'enfermer j'ai
vu que nous avons réalisé un très bon
score aussi je n'ai pas tout épluché
mais on a vu que la liste aux
rassemblements nationaux notamment dans
le nord comme on le voit sur la carte
avait était arrivé en tête justement
est-ce que c'est là aussi même question
finalement est ce que c'est un signal
fort pour ces élections municipales oui
bien sûr il faut il faut continuer à
labourer le terrain si j'ose dire et
s'il ya des ambitions qui se font
connaître et bien oui il y a il ya
matière à gagner des élections dans ce
secteur de sifflet 8e a même question
est ce que ces élections qui peut
modifier le paysage politique
yves binois modifié je sais pas en tout
cas nous ça nous donne une force une
force importante c'est un encouragement
à aller porter des projets allaient
construire des projets contrairement à
ce que des pêcheurs nous on n'est pas du
tout dans l'ouverture de négociations et
se demander qui comment on va d'abord
construire des projets des projets de
territoire des projets de ville centre
est évidemment autour de l'écologie
autour de du bien-être dans le sud
yvelines autour du cadre de vie des
déplacements bref tout ce que les gens
attendent d'un projet écologiste
et puis après on verra qui qui nous
rejoint sur sur les valeurs avec qui on
est compatible et nous on va faire les
choses dans le bon sens d'abord un
projet et puis après des questions de
personnes et d'équipements profite je
vous pose la même question kasserine
note puisque vous êtes élu à rambouillet
je serais peut-être candidat d'europe
écologie les verts
l'hôtel j'ai effectivement si une équipe
intéressante se monter et si
effectivement on a on a un souffle sur
suran bouille et je serai heureux de le
porter évidemment stéphane lançons la
même question du coût selon vous est ce
que ces élections finalement on modifie
un petit peu le le paysage
je réfléchis mais est-ce que ça c'est
fait et ça ne m'a pas intéressé
je pense vraiment l'effondrement de
républicain ça franchement j'y reviens
mais pour les yvelines c'est franchement
la nouvelle peut-être pas du siècle mais
en fin de la décennie si vous voulez
sauf qu'il faut quand même tempérer je
rejoins ce qui a été dit finalement par
part vous 3 à savoir que les quand même
les municipales c'est dire aux marques
et aux 17 chaque élection on disait ça
aussi des élections européennes mais les
municipales c'est quand même un scrutin
très particulier une alchimie très
particulière au sein de laquelle la
politique en france une personne plutôt
être partis politiques
oui globalement oui pour arrêter dit
pour un projet de ville un projet de jeu
très bien merci en tout cas à tous les
quatre d'avoir été à présent ce soir
voilà c'est la fin de ce sept huit
débats on se retrouve mercredi prochain
pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]